greetings it's Wednesday October 3rd the
church what's happening now is brought
to you by on it for all your
supplemental needs out of this there fee
understand me from the Alpha brain the
shroom techs immune and the shroom tech
sport those are my favorite things that
they have I also love the Mexican
chocolate protein give out of the try go
to honey calm right now I'm press in
charge and there you have it 10% off
delivered right to your house got talk
to you about something else
this is MMA weekend kind of McGregor
steps into the Octagon Saturday night in
his first fight in two years you can bet
on things like whether he'll win
straight up or whether kabhi will
deliver the first round KO my bookie is
gonna take action on this this weekend
so I'm telling you right now I recommend
these guys cuz I really trust them
they're family and I know you'll be
happy all season with my bookie and I've
do me a favor log on to my bookie right
now and double your money
WG dis use promo code Church CH you are
CH and you'll get the first deposit
match 100% that's promo code Church CH
you are CH you play you win you get paid
kick this [ __ ] meal ly the [ __ ] is up
funding applause it's good to be here
it's great to have you I never come to
LA that quad USA you go you're in
Hoboken what the [ __ ] were you doing in
Hoboken there is a I say Hoboken which
is wrong but I feel like it sounds
better than Hoboken but uh yeah so there
was some kind of Comedy Festival there
really yeah it's not great you know rich
did a show last night I went with them
so that I could spend some time with
them you know and because he'd just
gotten back from Ohio and then I was
leaving today this morning for LA so we
didn't much time to spend together so I
went with him to his show and and they
had a porn star on the show's porn stars
and comics and so they had this porn
star on the show I don't know who a star
I don't know it seems unlikely but she
did comedy for the first time I was
thinking what what kind of appeal is
that like who like isn't that the last
thing you want is do your porn star
talking like you know what I mean don't
you fast-forward through that part you
know and you just want to get to the
[ __ ] or whatever
don't you at least you're honest about
it [ __ ] it I mean who they know you
don't want to see that you don't wanna
how is that bringing people into it to a
to this is it
oh I gotta go see this porn star speak
that's like the last thing people want
it is because I got lumped into that for
a long time like when I first got here
people would have strippers and comics
where I was telling Lee right on Santa
Monica Boulevard across in this place
that when I first got here we go over
there next to a 7-eleven across from
Strasbourg theater but whatever second
happy thing on Fairfax yeah yeah across
him there was like a place 5340 then on
Thursday night said did Tom Lee and
burlesque but topless acting I mean they
would take a top off and the chick that
hosted it was a porn story that was
god-awful
but he had 400 people would show up on
[ __ ] Thursday but why to do to listen
to her watch her she just cuz they
should show her boobs at the end
wouldn't be more comfortable to sit at
home and just google it up she would
just be with a [ __ ] bang and dress on
and looking like a lady the rest of the
girls who went up would do like a bro s
type right at the end they would take
their shirts off but if they didn't have
a license around put pasties on the
nipples and I never saw the magic of
that appeal there but you take the 50
bucks and you pay rent them no no I mean
I mean they have it in LA - or in New
York there's a this friend of mine Karen
peahen does a burlesque show where you
going to do stand-up and then there's
burlesque dancers in between I it's like
great I'll go do it I you know I'll just
stand up anywhere any time but I don't
get it three or four year level I was
doing calmly a strip club opened in
Denver when the casinos open a strip
club open with to compete with shotgun
willies the biggest strip club in Denver
and they did comedy on Monday nights and
I would go down there just because I
read that Lenny Bruce book and he used
to do Carly with strippers right let me
get more stage and going nobody wants to
see me right well that situation is the
opposite
you know is it like you want to see
strippers if they're stripping but you
don't want to see strippers if they're
trying to do stand-up you know I mean
you don't want to see I don't know
listen I don't want to see strippers mix
with comedy and no [ __ ] there I think
I'd rather go to a comedy club and see
strippers and go to a strip club and see
communist you know can you imagine like
if you are I went out expected girls
it's just it's the same thing as when
you go to a restaurant you don't know
there's comedy there and then people get
up and stir if you're ready to do
stand-up in a restaurant with it it's
the worst it's so humiliating people eat
then they get mad and they leave and
they're like yeah when I know you always
thank the stars you don't thank the
stars while it's happening you just say
how [ __ ] rude but when I started
comedy it was attached to a statement
what do you mean it was five days for
1595 for steak night ah ah Oh prime rib
night or something
I may need a baked potato a prime rib
and a little [ __ ] piece of corn and a
comedy taken 1595 so when the host went
up they were biting at the same thing
yeah sorry busy nobody's a steak it's
like you can't do anything else you
literally can't do anything else but Jew
but I also felt bad for the future act
as the feature Act was going to rhetoric
they would be getting dessert right this
place gave you this play gave me a
shrimp ball you know they give you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ball that's a pretty good
deal I think right off the bat they gave
you a shrimp boat unlimited [ __ ] meal
nice shrimp which is just disgusting
when you think about that get me from
like some country who knows yeah they're
getting tons of the shrimp you go in
there thinking and Johnny Bananas
you dip in the shrimp in three days I
can't imagine that the waitresses with
servers are being quiet either during
your show right oh it was a nightmare
it was just a nightmare looking back at
it now like it made me the comic who I
am today
then I would go home feeling [ __ ]
defeated you know I still do these shows
I go you know because I don't go on the
road because I have a kid so I do you
know I say I do every steak and seafood
restaurant in the tri-state area and if
I do well at these shows I go home I
Drive home feeling shitty
cuz I've had to do what I've had to do
to do well and then if I don't do well I
Drive home feeling shitty cuz I you know
you have an ego about it it's like
there's no winning in someone so I live
right in the middle of New Jersey right
in the very center of that it's about an
hour you know so if I'm going in for
like a nine o'clock show or something
that's fine you know leave at 7:30 but
if you have to be somewhere at 7:00 it's
a [ __ ] pain in the ass cuz that the
tunnel gets backed up how did you adjust
leaving Los Angeles going to Jersey
having a [ __ ] kid adopt him like nine
kids cuz rich is like having Auto Rican
yeah he's got like 19 [ __ ] kids on
the side no he's got a daughter in
college he's got the other ones driving
his two kids are their you know they're
one of them's gonna marry the other ones
shacked up there they're uh they're
adults parent that's amazing yeah I
remember what he was like on the
struggle when we would talk oh yeah I
know he was you always talk about his
his girls and taking him on stage and
now we're doing the same thing to Rayna
she's 11 she's funny she's so funny
though she's just she said I said to her
one day I was watching louis c.k on
youtube and he does a bit where he [ __ ]
the stool and I was like Jesus does
every guy do a stool [ __ ] bit and
then she goes you should do it but you
should ask for consent you Kirsten
probably yeah I don't care and what does
she think you know it's like I feel like
it's like it's like beer you would drink
a beer in front of your kid but you
wouldn't let your kid drink beer you
know it's like some things adults get to
do and kids don't you know and there's
also like a time like she's sworn before
when it's been very funny like in a joke
and it's been in context or it's been at
the right time the right place it's
totally fine oh it was the first time
she cursed oh she used to do this thing
when she was really little where she
would she would she would go through
some curses
oh my god it was so funny but she's
never gone in trouble at school I mean
she knows we're you know it's when and
where yeah yeah I'm scared of my
daughter picking it up I picked it up
when I was young
mothers bar in Spanish and then going to
New York
I got a translated to me in English and
it never ended and that's when I'm the
filthy animal I am today so I know it's
a reversible like once a kid stops
starts cursing you can't turn that wheel
back well she doesn't you know she she
doesn't Kurt like she you know her
friends uh you know she's you know I
took her to her friend's house the other
day and her parents were having a
sleepover and her parents said you know
can't come pick her up at 8:30 tomorrow
morning because we have to go to church
and you know I was like oh boy you know
but she just knows when and where and
she I know she would horrify people if
they really knew so that stuff she said
I'm cringing I know she said [ __ ] one
day I honestly don't think it's bad oh
no no it's gotta start have a certain
age I'm an old school [ __ ]
there's no booze in my house by now well
pretty soon I gotta start going for a
ride to smoke dope or I gotta quit
smoking though yeah and I'm gonna have
to do it I have to do it oh they'll know
I grew up around Paris she knows I am a
bear there she knows I do something in
that bed you know many times I run like
wood like we run in and I put things
away like we've just been on like a
two-hour excursion yeah and I run in and
I wash my hands at the sink and she'll
go daddy you're gonna come draw with me
yeah I go get everything set up you know
many times I've got until you office I
go into the back I open up the back door
thank God I got that back door I fill up
a pipe and I blow the smoke outside I
have a big backyard yeah so I step
outside I come in I put the pipe and I
pop a piece of government I wash my
hands I locked the door you know many
times I've opened up that back door
she's been there waiting for me the
attention oh my god
so that means she knows once you know
someone's going on oh we were so she
smells it I mean honestly you don't
smell it because you smoke Paula but
people who don't they smell it on the
first time she says
I know for a fact that the first time
she said something to my wife her mother
about smelling some I'm done even in the
back my wife will let me know
immediately but it's over yeah you
better go to the office and get high for
Cologne on and for me I have to do that
I was introduced to drugs in the early
8th my mom had a ball and they [ __ ]
regret it yeah
yeah regret all this [ __ ] I did at least
let her make a decision but not it
[ __ ] I can't have a run right I
wouldn't I wouldn't you know you have a
[ __ ] weed is legal on that I don't
get none of that [ __ ] I'm telling you
there's a time and a [ __ ] place
for everything right she's 14 but she
comes to me and goes I smelt these guys
smoking weed then it's time to sit the
[ __ ] down and explain the situation I
mean listen my mother showed me [ __ ]
heroin coke and pop Wow six what because
they had gone to the Police Athletic
League and they took me to the police
station this part of the trip in New
York City and a fingerprint you they'll
let you shoot a 22 and they give you
like a junior g-man badge so they would
tell me like you know you have to report
mysterious accent should I know my mom
did something I just didn't know what
else I know she did something I knew her
friends did something and I still
remember seeing my mom don't blow Wow
out of aluminum foil you know like old
Cuban style Oh what women's night they
would play cards and like dominoes and
[ __ ] and they would do a little ball oh
my god by the time I was seven or eight
I would tell my mom to wipe her nose
like you [ __ ] embarrassing me so then
like when you got older did it get worse
did she stop doing it she is that so she
died Wow so were you embarrassed of it
no no no it didn't come up in the drug
report when she died it was just a heart
attack no no I mean was
they're doing blow yeah at that time
nobody she wasn't doing it like people
were doing it now man
it wasn't the way she had under control
she worked in a bomb my mother believed
for you to sell drinks you got a drink
right you know my mother believed that
if a woman works behind the bar a
boyfriend should never be in the bar you
know he shouldn't see what's really
going on no you just break away the
dream Oh Oh gotcha I'm a little Bonnie I
don't mean to no Bonnie's right every
night
Bonnie can I go out with you I can but
you never got a boyfriend or husband you
just don't mention you know where you
ring at work
that's how it makes [ __ ] money around
I'm saying hey you show those titties a
little bit but not enough you know just
perfect cleavage when you bend over you
gotta be oh go to Texas and go to a bar
every woman has [ __ ] clean little bar
in Houston you gotta show those titties
you gotta give me the illusion that I
might be able to score with you right
that's what's gonna get those dollars
flowing out of my [ __ ] pocket you
know it's like when you go to a strip
club but you take a stripper or
something you're going a little creepy
at the end of it I wants to spend the
night with you it's like maybe a Denny's
and you know the Denny's as you don't
show up you know oh yeah he's home
they'll always tell you meet me at
Denny's
I'll meet you there in 45 minutes day
you want a car [ __ ] put cologne on
your neck chicken every show the chick
showed one time oh and then she just
eaten breakfast we kind of talked we
kind of talked and then we went out like
a legal date like three days later and
then I told I was a stand-up comic and I
was in the process of a divorce this
could only happen to me at the time yeah
this cuz only you know you have a bad
luck streak like you know when the phone
rings do you like so they can't get no
worse so I'm going through a divorce we
have a child uh-huh
this chick
went into a barber shop where my wife
worked and sat my wife's chair without
knowing that's how [ __ ] face oh my
god
and she's like cut me up nice because
I'm going out with a comedian this week
oh no that's that's the luck I had at
that time did she say your name oh yeah
my wife goes what's his name
oh my god as soon as a girl got up and
left my wife yeah one [ __ ] up hairdo
yeah she's lucky she had years housing
she called me back the girl she's like
you didn't tell me you a man I don't
[ __ ] getting the voice you don't know
that's cheating them it's not cheap I'm
just she's with another guy I'm trying
to be the mother woman oh my god that's
a crazy story how crazy is that that's
like a movie and she was past my ex-wife
best chick was 23 bang and big fake
titties oh my god the holy could only
happen to me hüseyin going out with the
comedian tonight nice [ __ ] comedians
with the boulderr2 and I was one of them
can you [ __ ] believe that comedians
there's [ __ ] I'm aware with him the
comedian's in both the ball didn't even
have a comedy scene it's weird there was
a club called the Blue Note that was a
jazz bar yeah in New York no in Boulder
right and that's where Rosie used to do
a majority of her work
oh wow it was that place and the Denver
Comedy Works
did you try to say the no she's talking
about Roseanne who's got to be a
daughter today rich yeah he's got the
whole week with with us you know this is
a rare thing it's an experiment we'll
see how it goes
I know train I said you got a you know
he's got a he's got a short fuse so you
know they get into fights they're like
two children a lot of times you know
where he tells her to do something that
she won't do it and then he yells at her
and then I got a step in and you know
and then she [ __ ] with him because she
knows his little idiosyncrasies and you
know it's my it is what it is
they give a lot they're fun they love
each other obviously you know a
father-daughter situation is a weird one
they have especially the dad is a
[ __ ] lunatic I mean he's he's got so
many weird little [ __ ] things it's
it's uh you know it's like walking
through a minefield sometimes but but I
just called him before it came here and
they're all playing basketball so
they're having fun yeah
61 still playing basketball he does
whatever it is 10,000 steps a day or
something does that sound right some
crazy amount he's got he's always like I
gotta do my steps
got to get my steps in he's insane cuz
he still thinks that he's gonna somehow
he wants to like do stand-up with his
shirt off I don't know he thinks like
he's always like I'm just gonna lose 10
pounds I was telling the other day I was
like what don't you want to just be
happy like wouldn't you rather just be
like ads good oh great you lifted I do I
do a lot of dumb [ __ ] you you do you
look [ __ ] great thank you
Jesus Christ before we start the podcast
we're talking man when I first met you
it was at the improv was very casual you
never hung out enough and we never
really chitchat and I'd say hello to you
say hello to me I forget it we used to
hang out with in those days I like to
say it was like Doug Benz
yes Doug bet it was that crew and on
what who was that cuz it doesn't I will
calmly store guy but the guy would give
me spots at the improv from time to time
let's watch you guys and it was a fun
crew everybody was very nice but you
guys had your own thing well cuz we
would there was there was a group of us
it would work at the improv and then
also at the all in the alt scene you
know and we could do both for whatever
reason what was the name of the [ __ ]
place that did the obscene Fargo Largo
Largo okay and the guy's name where was
the place where Josh Donato was that dad
started at large a large oh wait it
might have started at M bar and then
moved over to LA he was the guy who
started Largo and then you know
obviously they they found out that he
was paying him he was paying the comic
so that's what happened oh is that what
happened Largo was paying the cut he was
getting names they were absurd yeah
doctor line up at Largo during the week
like his night was absurd
it was mine it was the Comedy Store
meets The Improv meets the laughs back
yes
yeah like six of the best comics working
every [ __ ] week you would sit there
and go Jesus Christ so yeah then he
teamed up with Mitch Hedberg Josh ganado
he didn't honor do it started taking him
on the road and they took him to Toronto
that's when Mitch got in trouble for
something weird and then supposedly when
he got back here it got to somebody like
he was he had Margaret Cho in there and
got the summary that Largo was giving
him like six hundred bucks a week that
is right he was not paying the comedians
he was just pocketing all the [ __ ]
this for him he was the first one just
sort of like you know he curated a room
you know he would only put in he was
very you know specific about the kind of
comic he wanted and they brought in a
certain kind of audience and then and he
and he was kind of a little mean to the
audience in in terms of like if anybody
talked they were kicked out it was he
really ran that show and that's why it
became the show that it became but yeah
he then they kicked him out of it
because no logo was on Fairfax he used
to be yeah okay now what was the place
when we first when I first got here that
was the hot hot spot in Boystown
what's Boys Town - gay area on Santa
Monica and la cienega you made a right
and you went around two blocks and then
you made a left and you walked around 50
feet and there was a the guy Sam used to
book it you had to go downstairs also
became yeah hot spot for agents and
managers and you walked in there you got
a deal like yeah like if you walk if you
had a spot down a Tuesday you got a deal
I mean like you walked out here with a
manager an agent well there's a thing
about LA back in the day was that you
would be you would do these crazy
sometimes okay we used to do this show
that was at the the basement of the
Ramada Inn like what the like on Vermont
oh my god that's
rooms been existence now it's a pot
hotel so it is yeah it used to be about
three or four years ago they turn it
into a pothole town they were doing pot
comedy in there ah oh great okay like a
pot hotel we need to pass smoke pot in
the hotel room and [ __ ] it's got a green
leaf outside it's a weird neighborhood
in Vermont yeah it was I don't know why
we would all cuz I guess was a Monday
night Monday Sunday yeah be like [ __ ]
open my kurz people just starting out
and then you know like Marc Maron would
be there or you know David Cross was
show up or like it was a Patton Oswalt
it was like and all places were like
that it was like you know this because
people just wanted to get stage time
it's not like New York where you get
booked on you know five shows a night
you know so you're just always looking
for a place so an open mic fine I'll go
and I'll get on and there will be you
know [ __ ] 10 open mic errs and you
know Janeane Garofalo and you know these
like big stars that were there you know
what was the comic book place I'm
Silverlake Lee just told me about
assembly cosmic vinyl is that still
there I just didn't go and call me there
the vinyl place yeah I that used to be
the old see the owner the owner no she
only listens to the podcast that used to
be the obscene yeah yeah and when Duncan
book that women ate a bag of dicks
you did oh my god cuz it was just so boy
it was like you know what what do they
call him that
hipsters it's a hipsters hipsters yeah
yeah he's hipsters before they were even
known there were hipsters right and then
they used to be a taco place that whole
area used to have tremendous calamity
what's that [ __ ] yes Silver Lake before
silver like what Mexican bar silver lake
was bad to give your free margarita with
you to the spot and listen if you were
getting a free margarita though yeah
pretty good indeed I remember if you
will get the free got margaery that
means you'll get into free margaritas
because you gave the bartender fin yeah
now you had to because you were gay
they wouldn't give you a [ __ ] soda at
these places like you were getting you
weren't getting paid and and you had to
you know put out for anything you wanted
at the bar for most of those places you
know there was they treated comics like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] in those days and the
promoters were making it a little bit of
money and they would break you off like
three drink tickets and that was you oh
yeah yeah
and if you kill they give you an extra
one here's an extra one was so great cuz
they they would send you your check
they'd pay you by cheque but they would
let you run a tab at the bar so my whole
theory was is I'm gonna you run up a tab
at the bar so they have to keep booking
you so because then they just take it
out of your check you know I never ever
got a check because that's brilliant
[Laughter]
people drink like and then yeah then at
some point they stop letting you run up
a tab you know but that what those were
the good days cuz in The Improv you oh
man we still get so [ __ ] up there that
was the party started
yeah when they had that big bar there
was so I don't know that's a but used to
eat there was a Hartman but there did be
huge stars in there to remember going in
there one time and on Ellen DeGeneres
was in there with Anne Heche when they
were dating and she was talking to me
and so I was talking to an Haitian and
an Ellen DeGeneres and Bill Maher walked
in and he sees the three of us in the
corner and he goes hello lesbians excuse
me I might add something that's what
Bill Maher you saying they're alive yeah
that's why I met him the first time they
put me on his show to do a sketch and he
was always like help do you know these
friends with Ron Zimmerman I think he
would drag him in there all the time
he's friends with weird people yes good
friends with the kitten play oh he is
yeah we kid the one that we had on the
podcast was best friends he does the
music for the show oh I didn't know
what's the end though no idea kid that
did the theme or something for it oh my
god
he has now do you still remember this
Bill Maher story well that first got
here I got hit because a duck standoff
dr. Sam Hill did Seattle and they told
me come down you're gonna do great and
about four three weeks later how I got
here and I remember he said something to
me goes we'll try to give you spots at
the improv but right now I'm not doing
too good there let me see your nails
again they're beautiful body yeah he
goes don't do this podcast [ __ ] yeah
yeah because I don't a button good turns
at the improv right now for a few days
I'll tell you we I'll get you in when I
first got it so I said what you do how
can mean them I think is I don't want
had a party and I [ __ ] some girl in his
bed so boom ah call The Improv complain
and said I personally apologize [ __ ]
with it I can go suck a dick I mean like
if you if you're that pissed about it
say something to Doug Stanhope don't try
to take work away from the guy that's a
[ __ ] shitty move it was you know it's
a different time then he was a different
person
you know you walk into your bedroom
somebody's [ __ ] doggystyle your bag
his girlfriend you got kids I think
something I think it was the girl he won
at the [ __ ] often crazy he was really
gonna bring him down
I opened for Bill Maher couple times and
uh one time I was in the greenroom and
you could hear the guy on stage the the
emcee or whatever let you know and I
laughed at the guy and he told me I had
to go to the green room I was gonna
laugh before that 23 years you know a
long time mm-hmm and you started in
Canada you up there for how long um I
didn't do stand-up in Canada very long a
couple of years and then I I moved to
New York is a funny story but I called
see in Canada when you were starting out
we were talking about you kicks before
the the we started the podcast but they
wouldn't promote you as a comedian they
would only promote comedy so you could
never get out from under the Yuk Yuk's
hold you know
you could never you know go sell tickets
on your own you had to use the yuk-yuks
name and people complained about it all
the time and I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I'm gonna you know I'm going to the
States and you know they had Caroline's
comedy hour was you know one of the big
shows back then and I called Caroline's
the club I just looked at you know got
the number and and called the club and I
said who books the TV show no one there
seem to know what I was talking about so
they put me through to the manager I
think his name is Joe fells Arana or
something like that and I'm talking to
the guy and I said I want to do your TV
show and it turned out he really was the
guy who booked the TV show and he said
okay uh you know he asked me some
questions about myself he was kind of
you know amused I guess and I what the
[ __ ] is this girl and then he asked me
if it was cute and I was like yeah I
think so and he said okay I have some
workmen in my office they're fixing the
ceiling I'm gonna put you on speaker and
if you can make him laugh I'll give you
the show so we put me on speaker and I
have my notebook open and I ran through
some jokes and I heard the workers
laughing I did a little crowd work and
uh he gave me the show from from doing
that so then I I came to to New York and
and did Caroline's Comedy Hour
well use this so that there was a last
year that that show was happening so I
don't know which what year that was but
mid to late 90s probably like 96 96 or
97 maybe something like that and yeah
this young I bombed really bad too
when they tape a channel and I got my
managers through that and everything and
then I had to go back for a little bit
to Canada and you know just a couple
weeks later I was back in New York for
good and I was like I got a a part Minh
tin in Harlem fully furnished apartment
for five hundred bucks a month no rats
no rat it was a really nice apartment
but uh
the woman who lived there just died and
the people were looking for someone to
just sort of stay in the stay in the
place until they could you know sell it
or whatever so I got I just got lucked
out yeah but no one would come visit me
you seized an opportunity what street
was not 125th and Broadway oh that's a
[ __ ] phenomenal neighborhood yeah
what use this so that was like 97 I
guess 95 was the last season of the show
okay so 95 96 then I was in and then I
only stayed a year and then and then
came to LA so when you were on 25th
Street there was a couple bodegas on the
block that's sold reefer oh I didn't
know that never went down there I mean I
I cruised around walk up to on the 25th
to the to the Kentucky for what would
then is a Popeyes absolutely yeah yeah
yeah there was a Popeyes there right by
the train station down the block from
the theater yeah Apollo's Fame right
mm-hmm yeah we get that was my weed
neighborhood but I'll tell you a mostly
walk the other direction
yes that's I didn't know that he lived
in Harlem then you came out here then I
came out to LA and I had a deal already
by then I got a development deal right
away not when were you on SNL I never
did it I never was on SNL that was it I
thought you wrote on this and now with
some [ __ ] no no never did nothing
nothing I I mean I told you sir before
that people would say right we're doing
SNL but they just I never did not know
it's so crazy when you go out there and
people tell fake credits is [ __ ] and
then after them I saw people actually
get stumped what give us he comics get
stumped no what do you mean like a comic
we go up let's say it LA comic would be
on the Tribble run and he would be an
extra on Star Trek The Next Generation
yeah the emcee would say it coming to
the stage you've seen them on Star Trek
The Next Generation and after when you
get off stage people come up to me no
you know what I'm gonna start Trek nerd
what episode was episode three
who you are you the guy who's like no
I'm the guy that won't pass the guy he
goes oh my god did you get the time it
was crazy they were just being your dad
well that's like a that's it I know but
that's like a shitty show to lie about
cuz those people really do know know but
any of those shows oh it's always
somebody in the audience who geeks out
on you this is one episode did you do
you know it's like when Seinfeld was on
alright when Seinfeld was on if you did
an episode of Seinfeld that weekend you
sold out yeah Wow that's it
you sold tickets because they want like
when he played the umbrella man didn't
die Moreira yeah dummer arrows on there
a few times a few times yeah that made
you famous made you famous
coming to Kentucky the umbrella man I
feel you buying tickets right it's so
different that you do I mean you could
do 10 episodes of a show nobody knows
who the [ __ ] do you know it's so great
okay like I I don't watch The Walking
Dead I've never seen it so if one of
those guys walked in here I wouldn't I
would just treat him like a normal dude
I wouldn't know who it is and for
somebody else that's the most famous
person in the world so famous really we
it's like person to person now you know
it's it's whatever show you [ __ ]
watch yeah I don't watch a lot of TV so
I don't like I don't [ __ ] know
alright I'm a comic man if you watch TV
it's kind of like now you're more
accessible to watch TV because you could
watch Netflix and Hulu when I first got
into comedy in the early nineties I just
stopped my TV had become something that
I never watched I have one in my
apartment mm-hmm but I watched like the
news at 5:00 I got to know what TV shows
were on I didn't watch TV so I came out
here and I got called in for my PT blue
and I said let me I shouldn't [ __ ]
watch it before I start auditioning for
this [ __ ] and I watched it and that's
that that was the first time I had
watched TV in like eight years I know
it's so funny I didn't watch TV at all I
didn't even have a TV until I met rich
rich came to my apartment in LA and he
bought me a TV that was the first I mean
I you know obviously I've been in other
people's houses i watch TV a little you
know but when I came to LA and I started
having meetings with these executives
and they'd say what TV show deal
and I'd say Murphy Brown or something I
don't know I didn't know what to say I
just I've never you know I would say
just weird things that I'd heard like I
don't even think friends design yet you
know or anything
when did friends come on I feel like 97
maybe have you good friends you became a
story should tell that's how she yes
right hailer so there was certain shows
of if you did those shows that weekend
94 yeah that we can do a hot that we can
make friends yeah that weekend you were
hotter than a pistol that doesn't happen
evil yeah but you you know like whites
told you before the show I'll never
forget they used to be a girl like a
group of common girls they used to go to
the improv the hung out with a guy with
a van that smoke pot in the parking lot
behind the improv we would go to a
parking lot and I'll never forget that
one night we were out there smoking pot
and that was a night I had a
conversation with you like I said my
conversation about cuz you will with me
or something yeah that's the manager
that I go and I know successful at the
time you got rid of him so yes yes yes I
had to pay him four years after I left
him
oh yeah cuz back then he had caught like
actual [ __ ] written contracts and he
wouldn't let me out of the contract so I
had to pay him fifteen percent or
whatever four years yeah he didn't play
he doesn't play at all
ya know yeah Brogan's manages Brogan's
manager and Kevin James what we were
talking about something [ __ ] I was just
thinking about that's how I got to know
ya a little bit you were telling me
about something you were doing I know I
just see um was that somebody that would
just go there and smoke pot I'm sure
many of us would go out there open up
the back doors and we'd sit there and
smoke with the guy and one of the girls
believe it or not that was hanging out
in those days was the girl that handed
up on Chelsea Lately that she travels
now she was on the podcast talking about
eating goat cheese Heather McDonald was
out in those days that was 98 yes
with her long [ __ ] legs and we
started the improv and go to log on he
was always a fun girl yeah then we throw
the [ __ ] that my Chinese restaurant
the legendary one on that street is the
name of the [ __ ] Street right off of
La Brea on I think it's Melrose the
Santa Monica it's a well-known Chinese
place where everybody used to drink in
the 50s Steve McQueen they just redid it
I forget now who the [ __ ] knows but I
haven't been in there when they and we
weren't doing comedy we just like I was
broke living in a carpet you were and I
was having more fun then like yeah I was
living like in front of Ralphie's house
oh my god and some nights Ralphie would
let me in sometimes he'd be sleeping
already
so when he lived in that place we had
the most massive stairs he used to live
in a place where it was like the the
highest steepest stairs to get up to it
and I'd be like why right he was still
broke this is what he was on we were
like yeah this is when he was in Doug
Stanhope Doug Stanhope had a friend and
rent and the interest and rented that
apartment and he went to Alaska with a
girl so Doug Stanhope took it over and
Ralphie needed a place to stay trust me
there was no stairs they're roughly
broke the toilet eight times
oh my god are you [ __ ] Hollywood you
know it was like a condo for like
Hollywood bimbettes in the 50s and
Ralphie's dropping 600 pounds cracking
the toilets and the car was rubbing he
was so heavy that the car was like
leaning down like you know and it was
like was just a 4runner yeah and here it
goes and he goes I don't know what that
is and I was like I don't it is the pop
the [ __ ] Springs in there that car
let me tell you something Toyota if you
know where that car is buy it and put it
in your [ __ ] showrooms like if you go
to what this is how your other place in
Denver and when you walk in the showroom
they had a car with five million miles
or three million miles something crazy
it got around the
twice and it still ran Wow they were
proof so they wanted all those cars
right here's Ralphie's yeah so Ralphie I
think Ralphie's nephew still has the
phone line Ralphie gave it to me one
last comic standing they fixed it up
yeah because it was right before that I
remember him talking about that he'd
done a pilot for the The Last Comic
Standing and then I was like it it was
before reality shows so he was trying to
explain it to me we all live in a house
I was like it sounds awful
you know it's like no it's gonna be a
great show I'm gonna do the show that's
funny that Jay Mohr created at the time
yeah that's how hot he was after Jay we
got an injection Jay Mohr was at the top
of his [ __ ] game for a while there he
was like on every show and and you
couldn't miss a game first he played the
agent right and then they gave him a
show on Fox that's why right right Ralph
we became tight and then he would
Ralphie would open for him on the road
in that process him Jay Mohr had a black
friend that was really funny but didn't
do it was not a comment no he was a
black dude that was funny and he would
bounce [ __ ] off people like he would
like Jay would keep him around to bounce
stuff I forget what his name is it was
him and Jay that created well Ralphie
was that extreme I went to uh I did I
opened one time in Vegas for Jeff Ross
and Ralphie was the emcee that's how
long ago and Jeff would say to Ralphie
every night you got to do all your time
before Bonnie cuz he couldn't follow it
even if Ralphie did five minutes after
me Jeff would have a hard time with it
cuz he was [ __ ] funny
he was funny so he would do all this
time before me and then I'd have to go
out there and eat it for a half hour and
then Jeffrey go on and every night we go
back to Jeff's room or Ralphie's I don't
remember but uh you know smoke pot and
Jeff would say hey what about this and
Ralphie was just so good at telling him
you put in your punch line before you're
sat up or you know do that joke before
you do that joke or here's a line you
know just smoke it not care
about it he wasn't like really thinking
and Jeff was making notes and writing it
down and he was just good at doing that
and you know well he got on Last Comic
Standing he was already a headliner
yeah that's it yeah I don't have to
understand that's why it was impossible
for that fan to win and people knew it
and they felt weird about it but NBC had
to go with some ethnics I don't know I
don't know what went down
but Ralphy I'm doing the same with him
at his house at 2:00 in the morning
while he was cooking he was the guy that
told me that I had to stop playing for
the back of the room he told me right to
my face
right right you know people think that
people like me like like if I say
something to Lee though hit me with a
tweet man you should have talked to Lee
that way I'm gonna forget like the
kaname advice I got was all bad like
anybody who ever said something to me
about my set wasn't pleasant he was
trying to help me well it's not pleasant
right but that's you know we were the
business that we're in is that there's
no school or anything how you learn is
other comedians so if the comedian's
that are ahead of you don't tell you
then you know that's like there's things
that you can't [ __ ] know until
somebody tells you about it you know and
now everyone's so nice it's like acting
class all the time you're great you're
great people aren't getting better and
somebody said something to me buddy I'm
gonna tell you what there's nothing I
might cry oh no because he was cooking
that as he said it to me he was cooking
he was 600 pounds 700 pounds he barely
fit in the kitchen in those days he we
have to do like a 360 like a robot in
the kitchen to turn around and that's
nice to drink all his orange juice and
he could go crazy coke oh really you
have me a swallow
juice he said talk to me one day that
was high on coke and I [ __ ] didn't
even sleep on this floor I just wanted
my car and cried that's how hard he hit
me one day and I never held it against
him because he turned me into a comic
what do you say yeah he said that had
blown up the room he goes you blew up
that [ __ ] room tonight okay
he's a funny [ __ ] and he said
something he was we were still broke I
mean everybody was broke I was living
off him he was living off his mom
somebody was sending him checks he was
opening up for Jay more like he was that
like yeah that he's for staring whatever
the [ __ ] he was cooking and he goes you
only you're not gonna get I don't even
know how you said it you said to stop
playing to the back of the room right he
goes you're not gonna meet you're gonna
starve until you learn how to plate in
the front of the room cow cow you keep
playing to the back of the room and
those people don't pay in the back that
comics right what the [ __ ] are you
talking about playing to the back of the
room what that fine open eyes I remember
getting in the car and pop in the car
seat back and knowing he's right
so tough lesson to learn it's up when I
go back there I'm worried about what the
comics think I'm making fun yeah for the
convicts because all the comics we get
in the back perform for the comics and
he goes you never see a successful
Comics comic because you'll never see a
successful conference family well I I
feel like you have to do a little of
both
you know you don't want to be just the
guy that's selling it to you want to
like it's like a Doug Stanhope or
something he's doing a little bit of
both he's still trying to make the
comics laugh you know that was a tough
lesson to either buy a [ __ ] 12-year
blocker so like in 2001 but it's true
it's like you you spent you see all
these comics making that mistake yeah I
kept doing it I kept doing it and I
would [ __ ] destroy the comics in the
back but the people in the front would
look at me like you're not funny you
know like the we learn this [ __ ] like it
was just weird yeah the audience would
do cuz all the colors have come in the
back The Improv Andy Kindler would go on
in all the comics were laughing and and
this was what the audience was doing
they just kept George looking at like
what the hell are these people laughing
at like we don't get what is going on no
we does be like
oh [ __ ] right there that was some advice
he gave me he told me to throw a joke
out once which you know those joke that
you got emotionally attached to yeah he
was like I know you think it's funny but
it's [ __ ] horrible like something
crazy that was like Jesus Christ and you
know I never wanted to punch him or call
him fat [ __ ] you know like I get it
because he's ahead of me you have to
listen someone like they say all the
time we're like you know the the
quickest way to get unfunny is to get
fans you know I mean like once you start
playing to people that already like you
it's like it's so easy to fall into that
trap that's why comedians they get
really big a lot of times they have a
hard time staying sharp cuz I never have
to like work through that you know
that's not me this year you got you got
too many fans I [ __ ] started playing
to the fans and started [ __ ] with me
I didn't know what was [ __ ] with me
and even when I shot the Netflix it was
[ __ ] me
yeah then after the Netflix on the plane
ride it hit me like a punch to the
[ __ ] mountain nose and I was like
I've been [ __ ] around for the last
three years I'm going back to say [ __ ] I
want to say I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] about the consequences
I'm 55 it's always a little bit of this
a little bit of that Oh what are they
gonna say you're not gonna like you're
not gonna laugh if you yourself yeah
they're gonna appreciate that more than
anything else I've seen guys that do a
movie that have no comedic talent at all
and they go onstage and they bomb for 40
minutes but they told [ __ ] about
themselves and people leave happy right
as long as you yourself
that's all they want to see right that's
what do you some authenticity or
something they want some authenticity
that's it that's better than going up
there and playing to them alright you
know I wanted every time I watch a clean
time and I go wow I wish I worked late
and that sets me back to thousand
[ __ ] years I know but wait it's hard
nights it's hard when you watch a good
comic you think well I should be doing
that well when I saw John Mulaney
[ __ ] special on Netflix I go where am
I
am i stupid I gotta start writing like
that but also you going through his
writers trap if it's like oh you are
right so I went through that I went
through that for about two years the
last three years and I just said [ __ ] it
no more setlist right I'm going back to
Konami store commie
yeah I'm going off the flow of energy
I'm starting with this is better and
wherever it takes me that's where it
takes me and if they get offended they
shouldn't have been out on a [ __ ]
Thursday night I feel better now I feel
liberated you know that's why I was
telling you I go out every other week I
feel very liberating no back to back I
can't give you that hundred percent so
I'm cheating if if you see me coming two
weeks in a row I'm cheating you right
taking money out of your partner spend
it on something else all right
I'm tired you know well doing a [ __ ]
hour while you're doing two hours a
night basically you're doing two shows
you know I was at in Philly doing the
what's it cut what's that cup called
booyah helium and I had my dog my kid
with me and I was [ __ ] exhausted by
the end of it I mean I was just like I
can't this is really hard to go out the
Saturday last show doing that last hour
I was just like I like five show five
shows we show combination I'm doing one
show on Friday getting the Train go
somewhere else and do two shows yeah
your city yeah I like that combination I
really enjoy theatres would be fantastic
and the one show a night yeah but you
have that [ __ ] person goes to the
house and so the first one is always
scratch you're like no I'm taking the
bullet but at least I'm gonna [ __ ]
theater now and you know I'm trying
Bonnie I mean you still you're working
on your 10k yourself you beautiful you
got the daughter but once you for me it
was throwing the kid into the mix that's
what really got to me that I didn't want
to be a comic that dying then they had
to learn about who I rationally right
my god I already got I already was
involved in a marriage that I don't see
my kid I have no communication with my
kids that she's been 1716 welcome me and
the wife just didn't didn't click and
you know I think about it with this one
I go what I would have trusted me with a
kid
25 years ago no wonder I wouldn't have
trusted me I was nuts when I was with
that kid the kid was five and that's
when I moved away when she was five and
then we just broke it's just about it
just something that broke it's like I
gave up a life to get a life is a median
yeah it was hard for a few years I
accepted it I reached out a thousand
times it's a different world and I live
with that now so I didn't want this to
happen with her no so now he'll
overextend myself with her because I see
it's the little things back then it was
I thought it was based on money and
doing show your kid your kid just wants
to land just wants your attention that's
it they want to see you light up when
you when they walk in the room that's it
that's it my whole [ __ ] wall is and
an iPhone X and that is it no I won't
give her for my wife that's a play with
her phone yeah if she texts me at night
yeah so text me from her bed hearts and
because I hire you and [ __ ] yeah I'm at
that level now where um I'm only I won't
live to Sunday dinners yeah there's a
rule in my house we got to be in for
Sunday dinner and eat like a family and
then I watch my 60 minutes well I feel I
think there's a thing where people you
know it's all about making it big but
really I honestly think the sweet spot
is making it medium because when you if
you're if you're gonna be a star people
don't realize the amount of [ __ ]
effort it takes to make it to that level
and to maintain it at that level you've
got to be working and thinking about it
all the time and so if you want to have
a life where you know like yeah you have
a kid and you have family and you have
these like you know actual real
relationships and and you know you you
really there should be more in everyone
always says and this country like dream
big dream
it should be like you know try to pay
your mortgage and then spend some time
with your family that's I don't know I
mean it sounds cheesy but it's no it's
not cheesy it's really uh let me explain
something I love that nobody knows who
the [ __ ] I am I love it I love it that
people hate to break it to you I don't
know if you know how many Twitter
followers you have no but people don't
know who the [ __ ] I am they've you know
half those Twitter followers have coming
god they moved on to other comedy now
and [ __ ] like that but it's so weird how
I couldn't imagine doing a louis c.k or
Kevin Hart that's not for me
right I even feel uncomfortable like the
Wilbur theater is as big as I like it
that's anything after that
it's to echoey I feel the people
uncomfortable if it was up to me I mean
I would just do two on your seat wounds
right of course [ __ ] I can't imagine
doing 20,000 what is I mean I guess I
don't so I get it I get it
like they say if you do the garden
anyway you don't make no money don't
make no money at the end of the night
when you add up the tickets and the
money the Union takes half of it it's
New York City baby girl Wow
they want you know 50 just few walk them
in there then it's security them it's
advertising oh yes I guess so when the
people do the garden like they don't do
it that they do it for the to say yeah
but it's it's one of those things where
you know you need to do like 19 [ __ ]
show like well I'm well is gonna do New
York County Festival he made me an offer
there was nobody right I couldn't
believe it like no no really like they
were like 25,000 for advertising Wow
what are you talking about oh yeah
Verizon Mars yeah wonderful you send
these signals to get it Porto Rican with
little flags right these when he was
stuck on a boat I don't give a [ __ ]
25 grand you know so you gotta think of
all this [ __ ]
guys they would stay in that thing give
each other signals all that [ __ ] went to
the garbage I'm an old man I want to
know what happened the Morse code
I was tremendous at Morse code I was
washing [ __ ] in Australia they
think they think I knew Morse code when
I was a kid that was a reason to talk to
people who don't know they would take
things back I don't know I didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on case you're
kidnapped Hanna you had a Morse code
thing in your house yeah you said
[ __ ] signals to people not the
people's are you [ __ ] it all but I don't
want to send more signals when you want
the 70s they taught you how to do that
[ __ ] in grammar school I think really
yeah that thought thought you let him do
the flags in case you boat broke down
you do want to send signals how to do
SOS I can't even imagine you on a boat
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna learn all
that [ __ ] as a kid in New York City but
I was a [ __ ] the king of Morse code I
can send that [ __ ] do you still know
I you think no I forgot all that [ __ ]
nice little pig latin too when I was a
kid my mother taught me how to TP
cheetah she thought all that [ __ ] Lee
isn't it you said ly to the end
something [ __ ] crazy why did nobody
span it's wise so you're doing oh my god
she thought some [ __ ] [ __ ] I was all
confused as a kid send them more signals
to people worse [ __ ] code that was
how bad to the bone it was
tick tick tick there was like a whole
little chart and you would just [ __ ]
with people I said the Moriscos
they couldn't chase you cause you know
there was no call waiting there was no
nothing this was straight up people
senator I mean we used to have one of
those walkie-talkies where we'd
sometimes get somebody on there do you
remember the Pittsburgh funny bone yeah
the guy was a [ __ ] pervert yeah he
was creepy he had lawn furniture for
[ __ ] that he had sued the funny bone
and broke away from them so he could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want I didn't know
that so the pole bar was pictures of
naked women
you know artistically taken by him but
you could tell this [ __ ] was
Harvey jr. because he had a couple of
they had bushes and [ __ ] but this guy
only went there with rich yelling with
their rich okay he had
so like Thursday he was too cheap to pay
the radio but one guy liked them and
they put you like am sports and then
Friday you went to his house and you got
a CB no dog he had something like ham
radio this is 1995 I'm The Longest Yard
came out I probably went there from 95
to 98 what is he doing on a CB radio he
would sit there I'm in my told myself
what time we get the first podcast he
had the first podcast go like truckers
and stuff something only three or four
people would listen to it I'm telling
you this is the truth of his basement
and we would sit down it was a he would
come on a.m. and nobody would listen to
it because I asked him like any movie
people might know it's terrible he's
terribly he doesn't know what he's doing
well he wouldn't know one of the last
times I went then we got into a fight
over that podcast because I said listen
we gotta go eat and he's like I told you
I don't give a [ __ ] what you told me to
be your phone's off
I said throw me on I don't give a [ __ ]
get me the [ __ ] out him 40 years old on
a CB ham radio - doing a [ __ ] there
wasn't even a podcast and it was 96 guys
97 98 how does that get me the [ __ ] out
of here and that was it after that he
never booked me again and then I heard
he sold the club years later into
something yeah yeah his own little radio
station downstairs in his house and he
would talk to you about the funny bone
his pictures and [ __ ] he was a creepy
[ __ ] dude then I just wanna know what
you said to those poor people on Morse
code and probably just imagine the [ __ ]
those they would get signals from me and
panic this is official business whatever
I was looking at my dog I'm looking at
my daughter last night she's five and a
half so rich is the cutest thing and I
was thinking about when I was doing the
five
I lived on 88th Street and my mother
would be do you remember yourself at
five and a half well this could only be
five and a half a six and a half right
because I was still crazy it was before
I got hit in the head with a lunchbox I
got hit in the head with a lunchbox in
Central Park but we lived on 88th Street
and my mother had a jukebox at the bar
yeah so she would give me all the old
it's that they would take out of the bar
and and there was and still to this day
people sent me pictures of 205 West 88th
Street it's the corner building but next
to it was a parking garage and we would
play stickball on there and you know
handball and there was a sign that said
for LOD shelter and we use it as a
basketball thing I hope you know this is
a really follow show ya the 80 and the
70s when I got here from Cuba everybody
had a fallout shelter because you know
the Russians right right but Venus
so I rebuilding would have a sign in
front of it that said fallout shelter
and it would have like a radioactive
sign and that meant in case of something
you could write lock yourself in and
they have like tang and vegetables in
the can right there they're ready yeah
you come out with the apocalypse is over
oh my yeah so they had fallout shelters
and I'll never forget that there was a
garage the kids would play stickball but
the way my building was shaped it was
like it went up three stories another
third floor where I lived now I can see
my neighbors that lived on the other
side of the hallway we could see that
yard where they would play I could see
them and hear them but they couldn't see
me so they'd be playing stickball and I
take those [ __ ] 45s those singles the
window the [ __ ] bottom level they're
like a boomerang
odd-job from the run I would just roll
out singles [ __ ] is doing that and I
would do it and then go downstairs and
ask what happened
[Laughter]
gasps lame-o what's all the commotion
about so [ __ ] somebody's throwing
singles up yeah this is crazy oh my god
that was such a [ __ ] everybody [ __ ] my
pants in time and you were five and a
half he's man five and a half of six
that would not wipe my ass arms up my
mom would take my other ways and staple
them to the front of my door so I
wouldn't bring my friends oh oh my god
and then I had to wipe my ass cuz I
wouldn't wipe my ass and she said how do
you not wipe your ass don't forget some
tough love there did you go okay next
time you [ __ ] come up with a dirty
underwear I'm hanging on the wall I
thought she was [ __ ] around
they put it on the top of the wall
that's such a mom I wanted its tail
there for a week and every time I [ __ ]
my pants you would staple them up
against the wall
like that like a trophy for me to look
at how did you learn to wipe your ass
like that I can't imagine a little kid I
can't imagine he throwing did you ever
get caught throwing the right never
figure it out until I got when I moved
on there so the damn who died there I
would wait though I have like 40 singles
uh and I would just do I'd wait till it
was a ton of kids out there on the
Saturday playing and I just don't
whipping about like flying saucers and
you'll hear the guys [ __ ] you die and
then also in that hallway
we were like flies I was a girl not a
pervert unless there's any of your
parents or anyone lived in that area
throw that time yeah cuz someone has
told the story about the record well
about May the 8th Street the FIR like my
father died when I was three Bonnie I
was lost my mom was a single mom trying
to do the best she could
you know she owned the bar yeah she made
good money but those years I put her out
like I look at my daughter and go I'm
gonna pay for all those things I did to
my mom those years were [ __ ] cruel
like this [ __ ] you can only really come
to terms with this [ __ ] when you have a
kid right then you start thinking about
your mom
I really do I really do I know the last
I was looking at him like I remember
thrown singles out the back [ __ ]
window I can they're going downstairs as
people be cut ahead to because what
would you set on fire I would set
newspapers on fire anything could set on
fire in those days I love fire - is it
that's a kid I was I loved fire and I
would set five every day like anything
that's light on fire around the colon I
had a lighter I had to figure out how to
get a lighter and I would light a fire
like the kids that I hung out with a lot
any time I saw a waiter laying around I
stole that stole yeah so one day that
was in behind that building in the
building next to it if you went around
the back that was stand down to the
basement and we would go back there and
do [ __ ] and one Daniel I start a fire
being like to other kids three other
kids and we put a bunch of newspaper
back then we lit this fire and in those
days I would light a fire and turn and
pee on it like I was gonna buck wild and
turn the fire off and this one dad lit
this fire and like this hallway it was
just a single person to walk down the
stairs and it was outside it wasn't
inside the building before I [ __ ]
knew it the fire just blew up and I'm
out of piss well how about a piss and
all my buddies are out of piss and we're
like what are we gonna do and hit the
[ __ ] I don't forget running upstairs and
locking myself in the door watching the
fire department go back there and turn
off the [ __ ] fire like we were crazy
turn off the fire I like any make it
sound so easy it was just a little fire
like nobody got heard about my thought
was just a stay away they just ignited
we put like a tree every day we got a
little cocky
Jesus yeah I was a little part your
entire plan was just to pee on it that -
but I was just a little pyro I loved it
what do you got with your daughter we
got time here I should I make sure I go
cuz rich won't really you know he called
me before coming in he said talk about
the roast he said if you don't talk
about the roast I'm gonna kill you did
the roast so my life hilarious
rich vos Transcom yeah it's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah so for his 60th birthday
we did a did a roast of ham with all his
you know his friends Jim Norton yeah
yeah it's tremendous and
whatever I don't know he wants I don't
know what to say about it that's good it
was really good we tweeted from I bought
it I think was five hours four hours to
eat up it's uh yeah it's on Vimeo it's
five bucks to rent it but you might as
well buy it for ten cuz you're gonna
wanna watch yeah my wife you were
watching my wife is a big rich vos fan
she's an American Indian oh wow right so
one night me and my wife were having a
regular conversation with Dayton in the
living room there was no kid my future I
think I was still doing blow and I'm
ready to go out and rich vos is on some
you know Colin Quinn show that's sure
yeah yeah tough crowd
he's talking [ __ ] about something and he
goes I did when I was a kid the teacher
would tell me to go lay down in style so
I would go away in the gutter with a
bottle of see yeah yeah yeah you having
a conversation with somebody and like
you both of you something yeah like we
both I didn't want to laugh she's
American yeah yeah but we both busted
that and ever since then rich is like my
wife's favorite [ __ ] that's crazy see
that goes against everything we've been
taught recently yeah no no my wife fell
in love with rich after that joke and
then Rogen's told me a couple things
about Caroline that rich said one night
like a long time ago that today ritually
got thrown out in prison yeah Rogan said
that it was him a rich and rich one up
the rogue Lino's watch this oh one of
those things like broken rich monster oh
no watch this isn't it funny that
[ __ ] one saying [ __ ] was to check
that I forgot who I forget the joke I'm
just gonna kill itself forget about
well he's I know like you know I've
actually for the roast we went and
interviewed Rich's friends and you know
cuz everybody hated rich when they first
met him as we made this little video of
you know them saying that the first time
they met rich and you know it's like
there's so many black comics that we're
like I saw him on stage I said who's
this [ __ ] white guy cuz he used to do
all black rooms you know that's that's
where he started he would beat him up
and he would go after
little [ __ ] Jew and and and they said
they'd watch him for a few minutes and
then they'd go this guy's got [ __ ]
balls and they'd like him after that
you know I think that's his appeal is
that he just I even see it now with
these you know politically correct
audiences is that rich goes up and then
they try to bully you you know into not
saying or doing what they think you
shouldn't say or do and that noise
doesn't bother rich he doesn't care he
doesn't hear it or he doesn't notice it
and he just does what he wants to do it
at some point the audience just goes man
oh well he's not gonna know which is the
type of time if you turn on them Richard
just step on the pedal a lot of home
yeah yeah old school type cars oh you
didn't like that job yeah well I got
another one to really get your pants on
fire and if you cut and wife don't like
that joke wait thought the joke after
that one yeah she's gonna [ __ ] a [ __ ]
pants you might as well leave right now
once you have that type of he's been
doing it dirtiest he's got funny in his
bones do any room spin it to torch room
take them to different emotions that's
what you do at that level at that level
you take them you control them like a
puppeteer you can really control them
you can push them a little bit listen
all my audiences like when you just set
them up politically correct I don't give
a [ __ ] about them right they'll come
around because they're like well I guess
that's the yes I may be you see [ __ ]
yeah you know what
you got stuck on the wrong channel no
you can't find the remote you don't know
what the [ __ ] going on why won't this
lady stop speaking Spanish on my TV yeah
that's me on stage yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm not gonna stop you know whether
it's the Comedy Store you know I'm doing
the Laugh Factory with Dom tomorrow you
stumble in there tomorrow night you're a
tourist you know you're like oh my god
this is where you wanted to be saved do
you know what the [ __ ] I was doing 36
years ago it wasn't putting my hand
woman's mouth it was [ __ ] gonna gay
clubs you get drugs
it was robbing drug dealers there was
not a [ __ ] day of peace man
I quit high school in 81 I quit in high
school in October of 81 that was that
started a two-year thing there with me
robbing a [ __ ] jewelry store going to
Sarasota Florida yes that's what I was
doing making but you never went to jail
I went to jail in 87 88 I'll arrested
Colorado second with you Berkley but it
was kidnapping and aggravated robbery
son yeah I went deep like rich you just
go deep on those drugs and then you you
know you wake up one day and whatever
but time to time well you can't come to
me now and say that I robbed you with a
[ __ ] I robbed
Georgianna cause gas station with a
water pistol in 1981 with the water
pistol what do I put I I think you paint
a water pistol
I took a water pistol just put tape
around it you make it look shiny they
don't know and you drill out the hole
there's a lot of times people show up at
the gun with the locust back for the
[ __ ] month
how long you in town for bunny um I
leave Friday morning you don't any spots
where you I'm doing some spots of the
store doing a couple at the improv and
then I'm doing just a bunch of meetings
and stuff and promoting you still got
some boss and my wife hates me podcast
my wife hates me yeah we still do that
how many times a week do you put all
that we do - we do one for patreon and
one regular you know and they're like
doing podcasts you're great on it I
don't mind doing them I sometime een
I think like when rich and I do as soon
as I get embarrassed like I feel like
we're putting all our [ __ ] out there he
loves it he doesn't care he's got no
boundaries
you know okay and sometimes it the
absolutely during it I'm fine then after
sometimes I lay on my bed and go what
did we talk about like we'll have
full-blown [ __ ] marital fights on
that podcast so it's all about that's
what people want to hear
that's why people tune in they know how
to be cool no man wants to talk about
the couple that takes that kid to the
pool their life is out right that's just
some [ __ ] television that doesn't get
people going through that right now so
when you guys are actually going through
that people listen if you're gonna [ __ ]
I thought my marriage was bad oh my god
I think we do people write me all the
Diamonds say like I hug my wife today we
make people feel better about their
marriage but you know we've been we've
been married 13 years and you know it's
as soon as I see other people get
divorced they say what the [ __ ] how does
that happen though we're still together
but you know what it is he just still
really [ __ ] makes me laugh that guy
even in the middle of a fight sometimes
we'll both just bust out laughing he's
you know now go then we'll get right
back to the fight you know we don't we
don't let go of it but uh you look happy
you were great man he's a good guy yeah
he's a good guy
god bless him I'm 55 and I'm like do I
really want to be doing comedy at 61 god
bless him I called Melissa quit no he
was some way it just came yes I called
him he had just gotten to Kentucky yeah
he was pissed yeah he was pissed and I
made him laugh and I thought yeah yes
like I'm [ __ ] I'm in Kentucky I know
what's going on like that's a great club
yeah that's a great club comedy on
Broadway that's a tremendous little Club
what they got ducks outside what are you
pissed off a little pond with ducks what
do you got to be pissed off about you
got the world by the balls
she loves bein on stage you like me
you're living in New York you miss LA at
all I miss away sometimes but uh no I'm
no regrets I you know there was a look
you know I just done an HBO special and
then I moved to the middle of New Jersey
and had a baby and sometimes I feel like
that was probably not the best career
move but then I came around to like I
have all this you know I mean I really
do have a nice life I have a you know
when you stop comparing yourself to
others I know it sounds so [ __ ]
cheesy but it really do so to realize
like oh my god I got all this free time
during the day to write and you know I
did all this stuff one day I was like
went to the dry cleaner
I just was doing errand after errand I
told rich all the things I did I said I
just stopped and I was like oh my god
people do that and have a full time job
you know it's like it's like really you
know my day doesn't stop either I mean
my day doesn't stop today I had a great
night's sleep last night oh my god I
didn't move for hey that's nice I took a
nap in the afternoon I fell asleep on
the plane on the way back from Boston
but last night was just brilliant and I
got up this morning with venom in my I
wasn't a bad nominal mood but I was
[ __ ] ready to go yeah yeah stop I
went from one move to the next the next
to the next acupuncture I knew you can
call me as soon as I [ __ ] like that
he goes you want to get that no no I
know I go no I cuz I was going in that
after I fly usually with a coupon on
Monday and it works yeah he cleans me
the [ __ ] out he even told me oh yeah I
can tell you because he does the
computer you hold the two the two
Magneto's at first and then he goes
through your body and he could tell me
what's going on
he said you got a problem then you
digest them yeah cuz I dropped my friend
uh swears by it I got a try this is
probably 13 years I'm on it Wow my
ankles just when I first started well my
ankles are really thick they had a
problem with circulation and that's the
money that's why those Chinese people
leave to be out that's why they they
smoke more cigarettes than us but
there's less cancer that because their
bodies are more oxygen and shaded plus
they do that Tai Chi they just go
outside and push the air that's got to
do something for you inside she sure
sure you look beautiful you know I'm
happy you're still doing your [ __ ]
thing you know I like doing stand-up I
you know I do it I still do it every
weekend now right now I can look at the
world oh I feel every when you train
that into be any human to put a [ __ ]
a target on your back
well you know I was I was when I got
into comedy was just to save me yeah I
didn't expect anything or whatever
everything has been a cherry on a Sunday
ya know so yeah I take the for this
right now
you know like all
after the Netflix come down to listen
I'm still sticking to the same schedule
right it's all about the agency Mike
it's great but well that's the thing you
gotta push so hard to get to that level
I'm still sticking to the same level
because that's the level that I work at
the best right you know that's where you
cuz I'm for me so about being creative I
want to just be creative we don't want
to go on stage I want to feel
enthusiastic yeah yeah it's like that
dude I watched that Molly's game and she
quotes that dude and she goes
success is moving from Harriet from area
to area with full enthusiasm yeah
and it really is Tuesdays Mondays you do
a podcast [ __ ] great
how do you mean I wouldn't even consider
doing stand-up today right I don't care
what you pay me I'm focused on the
[ __ ] podcast today so Sunday Monday
Tuesday is my podcast days right and
then you know in the weekend you do
comedy and then for a week I'm a [ __ ]
dad straight right I'm a karate I'm a
[ __ ] fool so and I'm enthused at
every level how many times you said that
your daughter's thing when she was a kid
though what am i doing my life an hour
[ __ ] ballet class yeah I wasn't that
thrilled about the dance class all that
[ __ ] but guess what you got to do that
you know what I see that you know what
it refills you refuel Z when I said
there were there after 20 minutes I go
what the [ __ ] am i doing there like I
get material I think of things yes I got
a lot of material Plus that she gets
older she's gonna be such a great
sounding like I've always wanted a
friend that just hung out and you do
bits all day with and that's what I have
I have an eleven year old that loves
[ __ ] doing bits all day you know so
it's like we go to the park we hang out
it's you pushing her intercom me no no
no I don't think kids uh I don't like I
don't like when kids want to be in show
business
oh thank god we agree on the ones that I
don't like it's [ __ ] creepy
yeah and the Crips these [ __ ] kids
out forever it's too creepy
yeah even three years on a sitcom for
these kids is traumatizing they see a
world from a different view they have
they have had that it's like it's it
[ __ ] with this natural order of things
adults aren't supposed to be talking to
you then hanging on your every word like
you're the smartest person in the room
you know when you're the star
a show even if you're only 14 that's
what everybody does you know their jobs
depend on it what days is the podcast
come out oh it doesn't matter you know
we don't just we just do it whenever we
can do it and put it out so what a week
usually it's Wednesday or Thursday but
and you have a lot of dates coming up I
mean I work mostly in New York on the
weekends in the New York area yeah you
stay Jersey you do the ollie Lange tour
yeah oh yes works every week in Jersey I
don't know how to [ __ ] dozen him and
Aaron the Reverend Bob Leavy [ __ ]
savages you know their basket right Bob
levees the way he's the driving force of
that is he really I think he's a savage
the savages like there in Jersey every
[ __ ] week I love it yeah like I live
in Jersey I would go on there too yeah
that's it it's a tourist Jersey every
weaker in some [ __ ] different made
wooden Jersey and Jersey's not what it
used to be there's something we could
correct [ __ ] now in Jersey I
used to always I think oh I think I
think Jersey still is I said nobody's
ever been like oh about a joke in Jersey
I don't feel like that's true
how about Hoboken this is the Hoboken to
Hoboken's got a lot of comedy um have
weekly yeah there's some weekly [ __ ]
there but still the the club is a stress
factory in New Jersey I have a show
there once a month first uh I'm actually
supposed to be there on the third but
the first Wednesday of every month you
have a show that yeah with the alley me
okay so Kathy you bonnie was great to
see you thank you younger I spoke to
[ __ ] your husband he told me you were
coming out and I go listen you know
she's always welcome unless you see god
bless them No thank God I thought yeah
you know you're great I haven't seen you
it's weird that we talked about Ralphie
a little bit we found out that this week
is his one-year anniversary yeah on the
sixth so it was uh it was bittersweet to
even do the podcast we'll dedicate it to
him dedicated to Ralph in there so it
was great to see you again
I'll see you [ __ ] this next
weekend in West Palm Beach I'm just
doing Friday and Saturday and two weeks
after that the 25th of this one
seven I'm a hilarities in Cleveland with
my main man Jorge Perez all right I want
to thank money McFarland for coming and
don't forget she's over at the stress
factory the first Wednesday of every
month she's a sweetheart
I'm so happy we got around the show
today but let me talk to you real quick
about something sure watching football
is fun but it's more entertaining when
you have some action on the games all
right listen I used to be like a
part-time degenerate gambler I don't
like paying the bookmaker it was between
some coke or paying the bookie so I
decided to snort coke but I can't watch
a game if I don't bet it so you heard me
talking about this for weeks and some of
your stalling the sidelines whether
you're an expert or a rookie you should
be betting in my bookie if you're the
kind of guy like some bet a little bit
and win a lot like playing the numbers
on the roulette you can create a big
parlay pick three teams to win it if you
hit all three you'll turn $100 into $600
the holidays are coming [ __ ] it's
not just football you can bet on
anything this weekend you got the MMA
fight right and Conor McGregor steps
into the Octagon against khabib you can
do this you can bet it straight up or
with where the help can be will knock
them in out in the first round you can
bet a bunch of things I recommend my
book in here because I really trust them
that's why this is the one bet I know
you'll be happy with all season long now
my bookie has been in business for years
they got great online reviews and their
mobile site is easy-peasy to use now if
you're on the sidelines now is the time
to get in the game it's October
you've already give it listen this is
the way to go this is the time to get in
the game and my bookie will still match
your first deposit dollar-for-dollar
that means if you put a GNote in there
they'll give you a G no but you gotta
join today because they're pulling it
that office soon login to my bookie
right now right now today right now it's
Monday night for at least put a betting
I'm gonna put boys sitting there like
I'm look for use promo code Church CH
you are CH and you'll get the first
deposit matched a hundred percent that's
promo code Church CH you are CH you play
you win you get paid so you put two
hundred and calculate you get four
hundred to win whit to play with this
weekend for kind of McGregor go to my
bookie alright right now and W
money use promo code Church CH you are
CH and you'll get your first deposit
matched at 100%
that's my bookie I want to thank my
bookie I want to thank on it but most
importantly I want to thank you guys
don't forget a West Palm Beach next
Friday and Saturday I had to cut
Thursday out of meeting in town and then
the following week the 25th 26th and
27th I'm at the Cleveland calamities
ready to rock and roll my brother Jorge
Perez listen have a great weekend stay
black I'm uncle Joey loves you kick this
[ __ ] meal Lele